problem 92 in a certain furniture store
each week Nancy earns a salary of $240
plus 5% of the amount of her total sales
that exceeds 800 for the week plus 5% of
whatever is greater than 800 for the
week if Nancy under total of $450 in a
week what were her total sales that week
so she earns $450 right so what was her
kind of her 5% bonus part so 450 minus
240 so she got fifty ten
she got a $210 bonus so 210 represents
five percent of her sales above 800 so
2% to ten is five percent of what number
all right so let's divide so you could
say 210 is equal to 0.05 times X right
and X will be her sales above 800 so X
is equal to 210 divided by 0.05 so 0.05
goes into 210 add some decimal points so
that's the same thing as five going into
four the decimal point there 21,000 so 5
goes into 21 four times four times five
is 20 bring down one two two five goes
into 10 two times two times five is ten
we're done so her sales were 4,200 but
that's not her total sales remember she
only gets 5% on her sales above 800 so
she sold $4,200 more than $800 that week
so her total sales were be 4200 plus 800
which is $5,000 right 4,200 plus 800 and
that's choice e
next question 93 93 okay they give us to
list so that's list one and they give it
they say three six eight and 19 and he
goes list two and they say it's X
three six eight and nineteen so it's
actually the same list except for that
but next year if the median of the
number is in list one above is equal to
the median of the numbers in list two
above what is the value of x so what's
the median of this list
well it's since we have an even number
of numbers it's going to be the average
of the middle two numbers so what's the
middle two numbers right here the middle
two numbers are six and eight the
average you could you know 6 plus 8
divided by 2 it's seven so the median is
seven median is equal to seven so
they're telling us that the median of
this list is also equal to seven so
where can I put X so that the median
doesn't change
well what if X is seven all right if X
is seven then this list becomes 3 6 7 8
19 and now the middle number since we
have odd numbers it's actually the
middle number we don't have to do any of
this averaging business so now the
median is actually seven if we play 7
there so x equals seven choice B 94 in a
certain city 60% of the registered
voters are Democrat and the rest
Republican so Democrat is equal to 60%
of voters and Republican is equal to the
rest so 40% of the voters in a mayor in
a mayoral race if 75 percent of the
registered voters who are Democrats and
20 percent of the registered voters who
are Republicans are expected to vote for
candidate a what percentage of the
registered voters are expected to vote
for candidate ok and mayores have 75
percent of Democrats 0.75 democrats are
voting for for candidate a and 20% of
Republicans so plus 0.2 times the
Republicans are expected to vote for
candidate what percentage of the voters
are voting for candidate so let's just
Express this in terms of the total
voters and the Republicans the Democrats
are 60% of the voters Republicans are
40% of not the Republicans of the voters
right so 0.75 times the Democrats the
Democrats are
percent of the voters so the let's just
substitute point six voters for D so we
get point seven five times point six of
all the voters that's the number of
Democrats there are plus 0.2 times
Republicans Republicans are 0.4 times
all the voters and so let's see what's
75 times six seventy five times six let
me just do the whole decimals 0.75 times
0.5 is 30 36 times 7 is 42 plus 3 is 45
and we have one two three numbers behind
the decimal point so it's 0.45 of the
voters plus C two times four is eight
and we have two numbers behind the
decimal so it's plus 0.08 times the
voters 0.45 plus 0.08 that's point five
three right here 45 plus eight
it's 0.53 or 53 percent of the voters
are going to vote for candidate a and
that's choice B problem ninety-five a
certain company retirement plan has a
rule of seventy provision that allows an
employee to retire when the employees
age so the employees age plus years of
employment plus years of appointment
within the company total at least 70 so
greater than or equal to 70 in what year
could a female employee hired in 1986
so 1986 is interesting 1986 on her 32nd
birthday first be eligible to retire
under this provision okay so what is so
let's say that Y is equal to the year
right her age her age is going to be her
age is going to be the year - 1986 right
plus 32 that's her age because that's
how much
she's you know she starts at 32 so 1980
if year is 1986 we're just gonna get her
ages 32 right if years 1987 we're gonna
get 1987 - 1986 which is one year plus
32 her age will be 33 so that's her age
her her her experience at the where's
her plus her years of employment are
going to be the years - 1986 right so a
+ e is going to be equal to this and so
that is equal to what 2 y 2 y -2 times
1986 plus 32 have to be greater than or
equal to 70 just so I don't have to
multiply 2 times 1986 let's divide both
sides equation by 2 and I don't have to
change the inequality because that's
positive so I get Y - 1986 plus 32 is
greater than or equal to 70 and then
let's see so y is greater than or equal
to 70 let me add 1986 to both sides plus
1986 - 32 - 32 so what's the 1986 - 30 -
that's that's 1954 right 8 minus 3 is 5
6 minus 2 is 4 right I was 70 plus 1954
plus 70 it's 4 is 5 plus 7 is 12 1 plus
9 is 10 so 2024 is an acceptable year
for her 2024 and that is not one of the
choices so I clearly made a mistake let
me let me see where I might have made a
mistake so a certain employee retirement
has a rule of 70 provision that allows
an employee to retire when the employees
age age plus years of employment within
the company total at least 70 right age
plus years of employment old at least 70
and what year could have
female employee the fact that she's
female shouldn't matter female employee
hired in 1986 on her 32nd birthday first
be eligible to retire under this
provision okay her age is going to be
the the year that she would the year
whatever year were talking about - 1986
plus 32 and then her years of employment
are going to be whatever year were
talking about - 1986 fair enough fair
enough and then two times so of a year
plus a year and have to subtractions of
my 1986 plus 32 is greater than or equal
to 70 I divided both sides by 30 oh I
see my mistake here this step right here
right does how to divide both sides by
two I decided only the left side by two
right that bite to that by two oh I
didn't even do that so 19 two times
nineteen eighty six divided by two is
1986 32 divided by two is sixteen
seventy divided by two is 35 okay so let
me rewrite it here so essentially I have
see that's what happens when you try to
do two too much at once so I have Y is
greater than or equal to 35 35 plus 1986
- 16 right I just added 1986 to both
sides subtracted 16 from both sides so
this is equal to 1970 1970 right and
then we have 35 plus 1970 so Y has to be
greater than or equal to 2005 which is
choice C and I'm out of time sorry for
that careless error and I'll see you in
the next video